all right so I mentioned this yesterday
is something to maybe do and people as
we will hear on the voicemail today and
also via other platforms said David you
really should talk every single day
about the gun deaths that take place in
the United States to really
contextualize that it's not just mass
shooting so I'm gonna test this today
and we'll see if you like it and if you
do maybe we'll make this a regular
segment on the show so just yesterday
yesterday Tuesday October 2010 of 2017
we had no news of any major mass
shootings in the United States and yet
twelve people were killed by guns
yesterday there was a one-year-old girl
yesterday killed in a shooting in
Virginia in an reco Virginia in Memphis
Tennessee one killed and three injured
in a series of shootings yesterday in
Fairfield Connecticut
there was a 41 year old white woman who
was found dead from a gunshot in
Lawrenceburg Tennessee yesterday there
was a 43 year old man found dead from
multiple gunshot wounds in New York
Staten Island borough there was a man
found dead in an apparent cemetery
suicide the only suicide among
yesterday's gun deaths two individuals
shot dead in Toledo Ohio both teens
multiple shots fired at the victims
reportedly from an alleyway one dead in
Tampa Florida
22 year old man found near a bus stop in
the city of Tampa two dead in New
Bedford Massachusetts not that far maybe
about an hour or so from David Pakman
show studios in Boston Massachusetts one
found dead in Queens New York one dead
in Chicago Illinois plus dozens and
dozens of people injured by gunshot so
the tally for October 10th 2017 in the
United States 12 dead yesterday from
gunshots only one suicide that's a
typical talking point on the right it's
all suicides we don't have to worry
about most of these individual gun
deaths because it's suicides anyway well
yesterday 11 of the 12 dead at the end
of a barrel of a gun
not suicides dozens and dozens injured
and bio the sisters so funny there's
this guy there's a right-wing talk-show
host who listens and watches our show
every day and he emailed me yesterday
after our story where we pointed out hey
you know 250 people have been killed by
guns since Las Vegas he wrote to me and
he said yeah well most of those are just
in Chicago
Chicago's the only problem well
yesterday one of the twelve one of the
twelve was in Chicago so also just not
true so anyway that's a twelve twelve
dead yesterday horrible every single one
a tragedy we heard very little about any
of them if you think it would be
relevant or impactful or important to
mention these at the top of each show at
the end of each show let me know